good
[Music]
hello how are you greetings natalia lancelot
and with your brief information for today,
thursday, august 26, the
metropolitan police is investigating
a homicide that occurred near serín
road and simao road the authorities
attended after receiving a report of
someone wounded by  gunshot around
4 am man in his 20's
was shot and did not survive
officers said it all started in
a fight which led to a shooting
this news following development and today
is the last day of the
bucks snow days incentive program  you have until
this morning to get the vaccine
against the cover and to be able to participate in
this raffle today
a million dollars will be awarded listen well there will also be
other prizes such as cash
scholarships and passes to state parks the
winners will be announced
after 6  the afternoon on our website
or our facebook news 8 nn
starting from tomorrow you can
get the vaccine  against the cover between
branches of the day sends around the
valley the one located on sahara and
stern the flamingo one and they estimate and
lastly to love and the young man the clinics
will open from Monday to Friday at
night from half past six  until
half past ten while on Saturdays
and Sundays they will open from half past four to half past
eight at night for more
details I invite you to enter
our page in the nou dotcom the
section in Spanish and now we move on to
the weather forecast  we will have a
hot day approaching a maximum of
107 degrees for today we will continue with the
triple digits for the weekend the
temperatures will drop starting
from Monday with a slight chance of
drizzles
nice day greetings natale lanzelotti
and this was her brief information from  y nos
now in spanish
[Music]